so yeah so let's talk about your your
plural serious question where are
founders right for not allowing women to
vote oh yeah I don't think women should
vote oh shoot sorry you don't think
women should vote no why is that I think
um right now there's selective service
for men which means um you have to be
like basically drafted it's it's like
the new version of the draft if there's
a type of War you have to you know go
fight and I think that's fair like if
you're living in a country like yeah you
should defend it but the issue is women
don't have that same right so why do we
still get the same Freedom like that's
why women didn't vote for before like
they always spin it because okay well
also they didn't want it they also women
chose we didn't want to they didn't want
to vote because then they had to be like
police officers firemen and do all the
stuff they're like I don't want to do
that stuff like we're good but that's
the thing feminism is always we want all
the freedom without the responsibility
that comes with it the responsibility
Selective Service